as we start here at home where we now
have a heat warning issued for tomorrow
let's send things over and feed
meteorologist chef moreno standing by
with more on this yeah guys typically
when we have some cloud cover we get a
little bit of relief but not the case
today temperatures still remain hot and
those numbers are going to go up even
more currently outside here are your
current conditions 109 outside this is
still four degrees above normal humidity
has dropped yes that's good to see that
however it still remains very hot winds
staying light so wind's not even giving
us any relief two alerts to talk about
first an excessive heat warning remember
yesterday was a watch at 11 o'clock at
night i just knew this was gonna be
upgraded now in excess of heat warning
and that does include las vegas because
we're expecting some very hot
temperatures from thursday through
friday specifically that's when the heat
warning goes into effect in the
mountains not much relief there's a heat
advisory for the spring mountains too
same time frame thursday 11 a.m all the
way to friday at 8 pm here